bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv fil
78 si vous nous rejoignez bien sûr pour
un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
vous pouvez participer au débat et poser
toutes vos questions sur le twitter de
l'émission hashtag 7,8 société ces
dernières semaines la ville de trappes a
été présentée par de nombreux médias
nationaux comme le bastion du jihadisme
en france souvent comparé à molenbeek en
raison du nombre important de jeunes
trappistes qui seraient partis faire le
djihad en syrie alors qu'en est il
vraiment de la radicalisation à trappes
quelle est la perception sur le terrain
des acteurs locaux les associations
culturelles cultuelles la mairie et bien
sûr les habitants quel regard porte-t-il
sur le traitement médiatique autour de
cette question quelles conséquences pour
ta en termes d'image pour répondre à ces
questions
quatre invités autour de la table aïcha
la caf ou bonsoir je vous êtes membre du
collectif parole à coeur ouvert et
président de l'association trappistes
mais la sauce dikra saïdi bonsoir vous
êtes blogueuse pour le trafic bloque
donc c'est un bloc où des jeunes
trappistes parlent de leur ville bon
c'est un peu court vous en dirai plus
tout à l'heure noureddine qui me louise
bonsoir ça vous êtes responsable des
secteurs improvisation théâtrale pour la
compagnie déclic théâtre et enfin il
nous a rejoints à l'instant mais dit
victime bonsoir vous êtes le fondateur
du traspy blog on ira on aura tout à
l'heure par téléphone abdelaziz al
jawhari donc le secrétaire général du
conseil des institutions musulmanes des
yvelines pour commencer ce débat je
voudrais vous demander quel est votre
sentiment sur tout le battage médiatique
qui a été fait à autour de trappes ces
dernières semaines et on présentera pour
le bastion du 10 le molenberg france xc
quel est votre sentiment comment vous
avez interprété comment vous avez vécu
toutes ces sorties sur trap eye sera
capitaine pour commencer ben pour ma
part un petit peu mal parce que
j'habite trappe depuis 1970 donc voilà
c'est une ville c'est quand même notre
ville
c'est important pour moi de montrer une
belle image de trappes parce que trappe
c'est pas du tout ce à quoi s'est pas
c'est pas le modèle bec français c'est
c'est pas possible
quand on a entendu ça moi ça m'a ça m'a
quand même s'il est parce qu des mois je
vous a marqué en tout cas pas bien sûr
oui bien sûr alors il ya qui nourrissent
oui je joue un peu aïcha parce que moi
aussi j'habite trappe depuis tout petit
et c'est vrai que au quotidien au
quotidien cette ville ne ressemble pas
au portrait qui a été fait dernièrement
en tout cas où qui a été souvent fait
sur la ville après juge à y vivre
moi je n'ai pas ressenti la voilà je ne
côtoie que des personnes
agréable gentil sans nier en fait qui
puisse examen probable qu'il puisse y
avoir un problème à des moments donnés
voilà à priori à des preuves à l'appui
mais mais mais s'emparer de la ville de
trappes pour pour pour lui faire un
costard un peu de mal fichu voilà en
tout cas pour être utilisée pour être
utilisé à des fins médiatiques des
fouaces ouais c'est à quand on y vit
c'est un peu difficile à supporter des
grains ça n'a pas plus choqué que ça va
on est habitué à un petit peu maintenant
avec les médias cette image des arabes
musulmans qui sont stigmatisés
systématiquement à chaque fois qu'il se
passe quelque chose en son temps comme
vous dire c'est devenu une routine en
fait ça vous fait plus rien on s'est
habitué maintenant enfin toutes les
sorties médiatiques la de faim je pense
à rossignol ce qu'elle a dit sur sur les
d'afrique ou américains pour
parler justement de la modiste magique
on a commencé à s'habituer ça nous
choque le plus c'est la routine
la routine mehdi pour vous qui habitez
pas trappe c'est aussi la routine et
est-ce que c'est pas grave que ça
devienne la routine ben en fait c'est
sûr que c'est la routine c'est à dire
que on sait qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya un
souci
de genre là qu'il ya un enjeu social ou
sociétal qui est soulevée par un fait
divers il va y avoir certains
journalistes pas tous certains
journalistes qui vont surfer en fait sur
ses peurs sur tous ces préjugés et qui
vont faire des associations malsaine qui
va servir soit leurs ventes de magazines
ou deux journaux auprès d'un certain
type de populations déjà prêts à
entendre ce genre de discours et ces
amalgames soit auprès de d'hommes ou de
femmes politiques qui estiment que ça va
faciliter leur élection leur réélection
donc c'est une stratégie politique qui
existe depuis tout le temps sap a tout
le temps été les mêmes populations qui
ont été stigmatisées
mais le fait de stigmatiser une
population ou une partie de la
population - type de population quel
qu'il soit c'est quelque chose qu'on
concours trouvé qu'il faut combattre
justement va terminer ce tour de table
avec le maire de trappes donguy malanda
qui lui également dans son sentiment sur
tout ce qui a été dit sors tu rates ces
derniers jours dans les coûteux le
problème est trop sérieux pour tomber
dans le n'importe quoi la caricature la
stigmatisation d'une ville ou d'éléments
que ce soit d'ailleurs je l ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois la ville de molenbeek les
les
et ça ça on va dire ça parce que c'est
une réalité des assassins qui se sont
réfugiées là bas ils auraient pu se
réfugier dans ma ville à côté
ils auraient pu se réfugier à paris
puisque c'est à paris qu'il voulait
faire le l'attentât et c'est à paris
c'était bien réfugiés de la première
fois et donc les personnes qui font des
d assimilation comme ça à molenbeek
attrape ou une autre ville c'est ici
c'est rap qui nous intéresse c'est faux
ridicule et indécent indécent parce que
ça mais ça met en cause une ville à dire
30000 habitants alors que que
malheureusement c'est un phénomène
européen et c'est un phénomène
international donc c'est des choses on
en parle avec sérieux et avec compétence
et si on ne sait pas de quoi on parle on
se tait alors justement pour vous est ce
qui a été dit comme le disais à
l'instant le maire de trappes guy
malandain est complètement à côté de la
plaque comme il disait à dire quand on
n'a pas d'information claire a donné ces
faux ou est-ce qu'il ya quand même un
fond de réalité et si oui lequel
quelle est la réalité de la
radicalisation la trappe comme vous la
vivez vous tous les jours à l'échafaud
effectivement on peut pas être dans le
déni
ça se passe partout
on voit quand même des familles qui sont
dans moi je dis dans le malheur parce
que c'est quand même un malheur que que
d'avoir ses enfants partis pour pour
nulle part parce que c'est nulle part en
fait c'est un suicide c'est un suicide
car comme le dit si bien rachid benzin
c'est des enfants qui trouvent pas un
sens à leur vie donc ils vont donner un
sens à leur mort c'est quand même
compliqué de comprendre ça alors
pourquoi être dans le déni oui il ya des
enfants qui sont partis on le sait c'est
ccvq c'est voilà quoi c'est parier que
ce qui a été dit dans les médias
généralement c'est plutôt exagéré ou
est-ce que c'est plutôt minoré en termes
de départ notamment vers le ciel bas
dans les médias moi j'ai pas beaucoup lu
deux chiffres réels
il n'y a pas de chiffres réels ces 20
ces 30 c 50 ces deux sens et où est la
réalité on n'en sait rien puis c'est
souvent les médias tu nous nous nous
donne à chaque fois des chiffres ronds
enfin il ya un à peu près qui ne veut
rien dire en fait c'est à dire que qu'on
nous dise 80 ça pourrait être bas 86 ou
que ces 80 ses 79
donc en fait si on nous dit 80 on sait
pas si c'est 80 tours on si on nous dit
40 on sait pas si ces 40 euros à partir
de là on sait que quelques quelque part
les chiffres ne sont pas juste parce que
il n'y a pas de il ya une espèce
d'approximations d'un média un autre
d'une information à l'autre qui fait que
de toute façon personne ne peut un
personne peut-être certaines personnes
sont bien renseignés et se garde de le
dire mais mais nous à notre niveau
pour reprendre aussi ce que vous disiez
une radine on est stigmatisée et on ne
sait pas à quel niveau en plus on se
doit de réagir on sait pas où elle se
situe à quel point le mal est profond
mais justement on va demander aussi à
guy malandain quand on lui a posé la
question combien d'autres applis sont
partis en syrie
60 80 écoutez sa réponse s'il faut en
plus tu m'en fous complètement faux il
doit y avoir à peu près je parle des
informations dont je dispose et pour
traps elle donc giro se sont fondés quoi
voilà donc tu es pas de renseignements
précis à donner sur ces choses complexes
voilà le chiffre qui est donnée là c'est
pour le département c'est pas pour la
ville de trappes et nous non mais non
mais moi je précise la trappe
c'est une ctu c1 c'est trop 1 c'est trop
mais ce qu'on a commencé le mans au fond
dès aujourd'hui c'est une trentaine
voilà et donc c'est pas 80 et là aussi
on est on est dans le n'importe quoi
pour stigmatiser vraiment je suis je
suis pas content parce que c'est bon je
suis pas content pour pour ma ville
c'est déjà c'est déjà tellement
tellement douloureux tellement difficile
et incompréhensible irrationnel que
c'est pas la peine de jouer les vedettes
sur des affaires pareilles
franck est parti oui c'est ce qu'on sait
une trentaine mais pas d'aujourd'hui il
y en a qui sont partis il ya trois
quatre ans déjà sinon en syrie au moins
dans dans un des pays du prochain une
information importante qui a ajouté
c'est en trois ou quatre ans une
information que je n'ai jamais lu dans
aucun média qui a parlé de cette cette
situation attrape une réaction sur ce
que j'ai à dire guy malandain
mais dis-moi plus sur l'association
entre molenbeek et rap justement vous
avez fait un article sur le tapis blog
donc trappe molenbeek et que comparaison
que vous avez jugée hasardeuse on la
voit d'ailleurs à l'écran
cette capture d'écran sur le site trapu
blog alors pourquoi avoir fait un papier
sur ça parce qu'en fait nous ce qu'on a
voulu dénoncer en fait c'est se moquer
souvent utilisée mais qui est qui
existent d'amalgamé l'idée quand on
parle de molenbeek
déjà c'est qu'on sait pas de quoi on
parle est ce qu'on parle du territoire
c'est sûr que c'est pas le territoire ce
que le territoire lui géographiquement
il n'est pas actif ceux qui sont actifs
ce serait des êtres humains
mais quand on parle de molenbeek on
parle de l'ensemble de la population
il ya plus de cent mille habitants à
molenbeek donc c'est comme dire trappe
pour vous voilà mais ce serait comme
dire moi je pars du principe que ce
serait comme dire pour un étranger qui
travaillerait sur une chaîne
conservatrice américaine fox news par
exemple
la france c'est molenbeek parce qu'on
voit les choses de loin on associe tout
l'ensemble d'une population à une
minorité
donc moi ce qui me dérange beaucoup
intellectuellement dans ce type de
rapprochement trappe molenbeek on sait
même pas ce que ça signifie c'est râpé
ça peut pas être la meilleure ça peut
pas été l'encours ça peut pas être
rambouillet alors qu'on sait qu'il ya
des jeunes qui sont partis d'eux qu'ils
n'ont pas du tout le profil de
trappistes donc c'est vraiment cet
amalgame cette association de termes qui
sont imprécis et qui à mon avis sont
consciemment volontairement imprécis qui
nous nous a posé problème et qui a pour
conséquence voulue de stigmatiser
l'ensemble de deux populations celles de
molenbeek et celle de trappe alors qu'il
faudrait trouver des solutions pour
cette minorité qui a des problèmes
qu'ils posent des problèmes qui existent
qui existe en ce sens le sens de nier
qu'ils existent et qui doit être des
problèmes qui doivent être traités
voilà je pense qu'en faisant peur en
associant l'ensemble d'une population
d'une ville de cent mille habitants en
belgique à l'ensemble d'une population
30000 habitants en belgique on règle pas
les problèmes on a tendance plutôt à les
aggraver
dekra sa vie j'étais quelque chose sur
ce cet article trappe molenbeek
parce que c'est ce qui vous a marqué en
premier lieu quand vous avez entendu
cette comparaison qui a été fait si je
ne dis pas de bêtises par un
représentant d'un syndicat de police
initialement avant d'être reprise par
une liste de la ville patrick l on a
l'impression d'être une fin de faire
partie d'une population de terroristes
en fait et alors que moi je le vis pas
comme ça au quotidien jeu
quand je sors dehors je vois pas des
gens kalachnikov j'ai enfin enfin je
pense que les gens qui vivent pas à la
trappe
ils ont l'impression d'être d'avoir dans
leur pays
population dangereuse alors que c'est
une vie normale comme toutes les autres
qui peut comme toutes les villes
abritent et c'est vrai des terroristes
on nie pas que c'est une ville où
peuvent vivre des intégristes fins et on
peut pas nier mais c'est comme toutes
les villes en fait toutes les villes
peuvent faire émerger ce genre de
personne et puis et puis même les gens
de molenbeek enfin on a l'impression
moi quand je lis les journaux j'ai
l'impression que c'est des gens
dangereux alors que c'est une ville
comme les autres qui nous il ya des
populations comme des autres en fait dix
victimes rapidement et super gars qui
étaient en fait c'était juste que je
voulais ajouter c'est qu'en fait on
stigmatise trappe et les habitants
trappe
les habitants qui habitent à trappes
mais comme l'a dit dit crain on a dit on
stigmatise aussi molenbeek par la même
occasion alors louise déclic tarde
collet molenbeek parce que vous y avez
joué enfin les juniors et rappelé
l'équipe des jeunes de trappes qui est
allé à l'année dernière
exactement en fait pour nous molenbeek
s'il ya un endroit ici un rapprochement
à faire c'est autour de l'improvisation
théâtrale
parce qu'en fait il ya une riche
activité et des improvisateurs qui
pourrait avoir un profil effectivement
de trappistes en belgique parce que
c'est la life biya qui est la ligue
belge qu'on a déjà accueilli à trappes
effectivement à une grosse activité sur
la ville de molenbeek et nos juniors
effectivement l'année dernière ont été
accueillis par par les belges à tournai
à la frontière belge
pour une partie du championnat du monde
et ensuite à molenbeek pour y jouer le
dernier match de qualification et la
finale et c'est c'est à dire que pour
moi quand j'ai entendu ce syndicat de
police s'exprimer tout de suite ça at il
pesé dans ma tête et je me suis dit non
mais c'est c'est complètement dingue de
faire ce parallèle la sueur sur sur le
djihadisme alors que bon voila quand il
ya des choses positives qui sont fait
attraper molenbeek pour le coup elles
sont pas forcément fait véhiculer
partout les médias et reprises je dis
pas qu'il faut faire un fromage de de ce
match d'improvisation là mais quoi qu'il
en soit voilà moi je
je suis sûr que molenbeek les gens et
pour en parler très positivement valent
aussi bien que la population de trappes
et voilà c'est tout ce que j'avais à
dire juste pour finir sur cet épisode là
je veux pas monopoliser la parole depuis
longtemps j'ai juste pour dire que ce
qui est important c'est aussi de pouvoir
être notre propre média sûr c'est à dire
nous on a la chance pas relevé de
l'improvisation théâtrale de faire en
sorte que nos jeunes voyage en france
voyage là il était en suisse encore une
fois pour les championnats du monde et
qu'on puisse accueillir attrape aussi
des populations qui découvrent la ville
de l'intérieur et on a voilà des jeunes
de rochefort qui sont venus par exemple
de charente maritime
voilà il ya comme tu le dis il n'y a pas
beaucoup on dit arabe alors y'a pas
beaucoup d'arabes à rochefort pour y
avoir été souvent dans les collèges et
ses collégiens là sont venus à trappes
pour faire de l'improvisation qu'est ce
que ça a changé
ça a changé qu'aujourd'hui ils le disent
ils de 10 m ça ressemble pas à ce qu'on
a ce qu'on en dit donc moi il faut que
je dis moi je le dis voilà je pense
qu'il faut qu'on ouvre les portes de
notre ville il faut que les gens
viennent
il faut qu'on arrive à accueillir un
maximum de gens autour de manifestations
sportives autour de manifestations
culturelles
autour de plus un concours face des
concerts en face des choses je ne sais
pas mais moi je suis sûr que le sport et
la culture
voilà sont d'essence sont les vrais
vecteurs de de ce qu'on peut faire de
plus positif dans notre ville et
et la preuve en est je sais que par le
biais déclic théâtre ou par d'autres
biais beaucoup s'en sont sortis et
trappes n'est pas voilà que un vivier de
deux d'intégristes mais aussi un vivier
de d'artistes d'ingénieurs de personnes
voilà qui est beaucoup de choses qui ne
sont pas mises en avant et y ait ben oui
mais voilà il faut il faut qu'on le dise
il faut qu'on le montre il faut qu'on
ouvre les portes de la ville ça veut
quand même dire par rapport à ce que
vous disais sur ces jeunes de rochefort
qui avait une image de la trappe que
tous les métaux hi media en fait tous
les sujets médiatiques qui sont faits
sur ce rapport ont un impact sur la
représentation que se font les français
hors trappe de cette ville le roi des
belges peuvent mais moi j'ai encore une
fois la part dans le cadre du trophée
culture et diversité on vous l'avez
remarqué sortant l'a remarqué et puis il
les gens me demandent voilà donc j'ai
déjà arbitré un match où il y avait des
représentants de toutes de lyon 2-2 des
cités de publier le nom de cette ville
de la banlieue lyonnaise 2 2
de chambéry de partout de l'île de
villeneuve d'ascq et notamment et ils me
disent mais qu'est ce qui se passe à
trappes
mais qu'est-ce que québécois c'est quoi
vous qu'est ce qui vous arrive pour eux
le voilà il ya eu 1 on a basculé quoi
donc
et moi je leur dis bah non au quotidien
rien n'a changé c'est juste que voilà
lisser l'image qu'on en donne et il faut
militer est vraiment moi j'ai je suis
horrifié quand on voit quand on voit
quand on fait un google de trappes et
plus voile les articles qui sortent en
premier je me dis c'est bien batman
reluisant pour la ville c'est bien
dommage mais c'est bien dommage alors
abdel aziz al zaouahri est avec nous par
téléphone c'est le secrétaire général du
simi le conseil des institutions
musulmanes des yvelines bonsoir oui bon
choix
alors on a entendu beaucoup dans les
médias nationaux notamment france inter
pour ne pas les citer
pointé du doigt l'omerta sur le sujet de
la radicalisation la trappe en disant
notamment que la grande mosquée ou que
les autres mosquées présente attraper
les musulmans en général de trappes
refusait de parler de cette réalité de
la radicalisation qu'est ce que vous
avez à répondre à ça oui c'est dommage
j'ai fait des médias ne viennent pas
voir la beauté les acteurs de trappes
sur un tas d'autres d'événements et
internautes des initiatives qui sont
plutôt constructif qui ont lieu tout au
long de l'année
donc aujourd'hui en effet il ya un vrai
sujet il faut pas l'occulter
la question de la radicalisation et les
informations à vérifier d'ailleurs pas
recueilli que les choses sont dans la
même ampleur que ce qui est dit
aujourd'hui dans certains médias
voilà je suis pas sûr que ce soit
exactement dans la même ampleur
maintenant il ya un vrai sujet il faut
pas occulter certes mais aller jusqu'à
coller une étiquette sur les
responsables communautaires ou sur la
ville de trappes
comme quoi ça fait un fief du
radicalisme
au niveau national c'est juste un peu
irresponsable parce que derrière senna
page et ce pendant une visite chez des
habitants c'est un tissu économique
social c'est des familles et des jeunes
les moins jeunes avec toutes les
conséquences que ça peut que ça peut
avoir
maintenant il est comme je le disais il
ya un vrai sujet auquel les responsables
est-ce que ce soit la mosquée de travaux
les autres et ils ont déjà pris part à
ce débat là parce que on participe
pourtant que si la mosquée de trappes
également certain nombre de deux comment
dire de se passer d'un scoop et déjà
d'un stand pour évaluer la situation
mais aussi d'action contre le ce
discours de radicalisation et jusqu'à
preuve du contraire jusqu'à maintenant
toutes les personnes qui ont été mis en
cause dans tracks royaume n'ont pas de
liens avec les institutions musulmanes
officielle donc tout se passe dans des
réseaux parallèles tout se passe sur les
réseaux sociaux tout se passe donc là où
l'on dessert qui dépasse largement la
mosquée des travaux les responsables
communautaires ont donc quelque chose
qui dit qui y est organisée à l'échelle
internationale et je vois pas qu'est ce
que le responsable d'une association
locale
on peut répondre ou peut faire tout seul
face à ça mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'ils n'ont pas de rôle à jouer ils
sont déjà en train de lui vouer et
rapidement pour terminer parce qu'elle a
les on n'est pas très bonne le cfcm donc
le conseil du culte français musulmans a
annoncé qu'ils allaient préparer un
contre un contre discours religieux pour
justement essayer de sortir les jeunes
radicaliser de cette emprise religieuse
qu'en pensez vous en fait d'un point de
vue religieux le contre-discours en
question il existe déjà je veux dire
religieusement parlant il n'a jamais été
question d'aller commettre des crimes ou
d'aller porter atteinte à ceux qui sont
différemment
11 on croit différemment de soins ne
crois pas du tout donc c'est tout
simplement remettre les points sur les i
de ce point de vue là est en effet les
responsables religieux des imams les
institutions religieuses doivent
rappeler tout simplement ses principes
de base de ces principes fondamentaux
maintenant en effet par rapport à un
certain nombre d'arguments terre qui
peuvent circuler sur les réseaux sociaux
justement à destination des jeunes
d'intervenants ou d'un public un peu
plus fragiles
en effet il ya des actions à mener en
place et puis il ya pas plus loin que
hier on était en conseil du conseil des
institutions musulmanes des édiles est
une des actions qui justement c'est
d'organiser des séminaires de formation
de conférences à faire est justement sur
ces sujets là on trouvera faire tourner
dans les différents de l'étude des
yvelines très bien qu'on peut pas venir
et dire que du dossier très bien d'el
hadjar et merci d'avoir attaqué ou par
téléphone
vous allez on va terminer cette émission
à chaque fois en parlant peut-être des
actions qui sont mises en place
quotidiennement par les associations
comme la vôtre mais la sauce déclic
théâtre ou d'autres encore peut-être
pour essayer de proposer autre chose à
ces jeunes chose qu'on voit assez peu
médiatiquement mais justement je veux
dire avant de faire la répression comme
on peut le faire actuellement il
faudrait peut-être faire déjà de la
prévention comme le dit monsieur g
houari effectivement on peut penser que
ça soit la mosquée de trappes mais c'est
pas ce n'est pas la réalité c'est
sûrement pas la réelle
et puisque les discours quand même reste
l'islam c'est quand même quelque chose
de ces la paix c'est c'est que c'est
quelque chose de tranquille quoi c'est
pas du tout la vue de l'islam qu'on en a
et franchement faut faire des actions
pour pouvoir que ces jeunes qu'ils
soient au lieu que ces jeunes traînent
un peu partout et reçoivent un discours
qui soit on leur propose quand même des
belles choses quand on y réfléchit c'est
une jeune fille qui accroche toi season
à ce que vous leur proposez c'est des
jeunes qui qui qui ne font rien entre
guillemets de leur vie on leur propose
quand même pas mal de choses à faire
et voilà après faut aussi que les
municipalités suivent parce que les les
associations comme vous le savez n'ont
pas de budget nous en tout cas à
attraper la sauce on ne demande pas de
subventions parce que déjà c'est très
compliqué et puis pour nous c'est notre
méthode de travail donc on préfère faire
comme ça ensuite trappe mais la sauce
c'est bien mais on fait aussi pour les
enfants pour les mamans tout ça c'est
sortir les gens de ce clivage et deux de
leurs assemblées de voile à prendre et
puis et puis tout le monde dansait pas
il n'y a pas que des mamans et aussi les
messieurs il ya aussi des jeunes et
aussi des ressemblances
intergénérationnel c'est ce qu'on a fait
la dernière fois avec en partenariat
avec les mamans du coeur parce qu'on a
fait une journée intergénérationnelle
voilà et après ensuite par rapport aux
actions maya le collectif puisque le
collectif parallèle ont rouvert a été
créé en février de l'année dernière
suite aux événements et ce collectif
permet aux gens de venir et et de parler
parce que derrière un enfant qui est
parti bah il n'y a pas que l'enfant et à
toute une famille c'est beaucoup de ce
niveau justement famille de trappes sont
connus parlera par tout le monde dansait
pas voilà
et maman quand on les rencontre il y en
a plein qui se rencontrent au marché etc
et se disent voilà les parties ton fils
est parti comment va ton fils comment
ceux ci il ya des enfants quand même
trappistes qui sont décédés là bas c'est
difficile dans laquelle louis pour vous
aussi
c'est l'action principal c'est d'essayer
de faire en sorte que les jeunes que
vous avez à déclic théâtre alla soit le
plus ouvert possible qu'il puisse
partager découvrir et sortir aussi un
petit peu de la ville pour voir ça se
passe à l'extérieur nous régulièrement
effectivement on essaye de les emmener
comme je vous le disais être véhiculé
avec leurs propres médias ne pas passer
par le filtre de la télévision ou
d'internet se montrer en direct montrer
qu'ils sont en direct montre ils sont
brillants montré que qui sont qu'ils
sont ensemble qui peuvent être avec les
autres surtout est également
je pense qu'on a une responsabilité en
tant qu'adulte aussi tous autant connaît
que ce soit dans notre travail ou ou
même en tant que citoyen c'est de près
de 2,2 de poser le doigt quand quand on
attend quand on entend quelque chose qui
qui qui est synonyme d'une sommes pas
d'une déviance et extrêmement unie d'un
extremis à l'accueil de jour mais mais
mais même si on veut pas voilà il faut
il faut un moment donné signe enfin
signalé je dis pas mais moi je comprends
compris il faut pas hésité à pointer du
doigt quand on entend des choses ou
qu'on voit des choses extrêmement
radical hugues voyez les planches
merci à tous les cas c'est déjà fini ça
passe très vite pour un débat
intéressant vous pourrez continuer chez
vous n'hésitez pas à échanger à parler
et à partager cette émission vous pouvez
la retrouver sur le site de tv file donc
www.tv fil 78 points comme bonne suite
de programmes et bonne soirée à tous